[Music]
my dress I'm saying a safe house in
Paris why would I need a safe house
embarrassed rude things at some point go
terribly wrong it's good to have a place
to go you know for a cup of tea I had
brothers my sisters the clock is ticking
fast
my dream we who live forces before us
the moment has come to take our rightful
place
in a world where we was it's pretty
join me
or die The Wizarding of nine Wizarding
World had been a piece for over a
century
Windell world wants to see that piece
destroyed
[Music]
you want me to hunt him down to kill him
[Music]
Damodar why can't you go I can another
guy's cools off
it has to be here
you don't suffer from motion sickness
see I don't do well on boats you'll be
fine
Jenny why I admire eunuch you do not
seek power you simply ask is the thing
right
[Music]
the times coming
when you have to pick a side
[Music]
I don't do science
[Music]
I think you something
you'd you never met a monster you
couldn't love let's take
that's her brother I think that might
have been the best moment of my life
[Music]